yeah welcome to this video five-minute
game and playing them very very old
dress rehear not old in terms of H this
is Graham international master damn over
from from Italy and he's playing on the
SSC for yes and I played awesome played
him so often pretty good play especially
in blitz okay so we got a Kings Indian
attack already let's say um yeah I know
it's Kings Indian attack with you fall
and I played on a solid set up with with
c6 Bishop g4 Tom looks fairly am fairly
am to normal this position yeah white
intends to play Knight to f5 dumb yeah
should I play Knight c5 yeah maybe I
don't mind to exchange them some pieces
the night on b3 can be somewhat annoying
and with with the check on the FI porn
so he retreated surprisingly the Sun
looks a bit passive to me but maybe it
is some that is survival he probably
wants to go night see form and whatever
HSP 5 control this square it weakens d5
of course but um not sure how how
terrible that this actually is okay so
yeah this not only five is annoying I
don't want to take at the moment um I'd
rather prefer to take and play our E for
if then if possible this shouldn't be
too bad a half night to be 3m a five is
also also hanging so should I play a
form yeah why not looks like I've got
pretty decent down development and not
sure that this is so dangerous here just
put the Queen on b6 it's an active
square putting some pressure on the f
porn until maybe I can just go age six
next movement get rid of the bishop yeah
it probably wants to retreat it all the
way back to see one I wonder what what
about before I day three just creating a
passed pawn here I mean this is all nice
but what is doing but it's not really
threatening much and I don't f five is
nice but really it's not doing not doing
something terrible to my position
yeah maybe the Sun is an idea on still
95 cannot take here but um 95 but let's
um let's get on with this and it i need
to say pond and suppose the idea and not
sure that delaying this this plenum
brings me any benefits yeah i take with
the porn 95 i have got a constant
worries about the gee-gees the poor non
non f6 so i'd rather take what the Queen
okay yeah maybe I should have paid
attention to 97 I'm really didn't look
look much and in da porn is just the the
important thing in this position didn't
really pay attention to the smooth maybe
he could have played it i mean yeah he
wants you want to i'm control the
default square this is certainly am a
useful idea i didn't go queen c6 because
of quincy three but now quincy three
obviously it's not possible anymore okay
let's make
some look for the king and get out of
possible 97 checks and stuff it's clear
that black guy that black has an
advantage now I got the two bishops
enter the strong on the stronger porn
now aged 54 threatened so think I needed
to react react to that so do I want to
get the quince off probably if it
doesn't exchange I can go Quincy form
yeah maybe should be a bad square do I
threaten queen take 35 mm maybe going to
XD five feet maybe can take a form so
this probably doesn't help much that's
um just improve the position slightly
not quite sure how to make progress yet
and I thought Bishop them just be sure
before maybe I'm overlooking a trick I
just rook rookie form okay but I can wow
this is check and 24 Bishop d3 ah it's a
pain really completely outplayed him and
just overlook this you should be three
stuff so queen d 5 root k for us to
check cause ya don't have a fav a move
yeah okay yeah really a silly game I
mean this is simply simply terrible for
white let's have a quick look on how to
win this yeah rook takes e4
indisposition wins as the rook on f1 is
hanging okay this is some something you
can overlook in the Blitz game now rook
be eight okay yeah I relied on Bishop
before but them simply simply overlooked
Bishop d3 I can still take the 5 p.m.
and still have a pretty good it big
advantage so I'm just a bad game at the
end
yeah before that it was quite ok but
just overlooked Bishop d3 yeah all right
thanks for watching